[Applaudissements]
j'ai un truc à dire bravo avec plaisir
tu as été vraiment très bon pendant
qu'il pour metz est très beau ça ouais
ça va donner c'est une belle couleur
bravo virginie ledoyen on est à fond
dans la main ont chanté tout à rl tous
les mecs quand il fait chaud de wipeout
des commandes sera pas sur le terrain
pas tous les sens je vois tu leur as tu
dis oui j fans des pizzas machin et tout
est arrivé et il voit tout il a de la
télé là des tic tac aussi exactement je
dois faire aussi du tic-tac est à la
fois mais d'abord hier soir c'était
l'amour est dans le pré
ouais et sur m6 c'était l'événement de
la soirée parce que pour la première
fois en 15 saisons il ya une star
internationale qui a participé à
l'émission qui abat vous allez boire
c'est vrai que c'est hyper
impressionnant convoi gardez vous
regardez en fait tout c'est pareil tu te
trouves pas beau alors que moi je trouve
beau mais c'est vrai oui je t'appelle
des zones samba
oui oui si tu ressembles jason statham
[Applaudissements]
à quelque chose d'indécent vous adjani
pour ressembler à quelqu'un vous auto de
la table bernard montiel
ah non non rien à sa survie nathalie
simon sebag web assez oui c'est oui vous
hélène rollès nicolas hulot tout le
temps il faut l'avouer mais le bull un
arrière goût
catherine laborde bah oui c'est vrai
vous heureux néo pas d'avis que tu
ressembles à quelqu'un patrick sébastien
s'est montré très frais
[Applaudissements]
autre chantier un truc très méchant
angelina jolie y penser c'est vrai c'est
vrai ou sinon side de l'âge de glace
[Rires]
c'est vrai qu'elle est magnifique
dany vous et moi christophe rocancourt
ah oui c'est vrai il quitterait coin est
bien fidèle à ce qu'on nous a déjà pris
pour quelqu'un de raciste ayant fait
mais c'est pas vous reconnaît tout de
suite on dit c'est bien j'ai eu droit à
un bain on dit ouais nous on dit rien
l'allemand dit un truc c'est qu'on sait
moins mais voilà c'est comme moi cette
fois c'est toujours pareil au loup n'est
pas de les coupeurs ces intrus dos et
relais vincent collet c'est le stoppe le
principe on regarde une image on zoome
on fait un sport c'est génial et ben
voilà c'est maintenant c'est de toi ça
bien sûr dans le 19 45 sur m6 un
journaliste a visiblement eu un peu de
mal à gérer son stress
il faut en revanche nathalie être
beaucoup plus prudent pour le deuxième
homme parce qu'il a été vu stop
mais qu'est ce qui a été vu est-ce qu'on
nommerait pas un peu sur son pantalon la
pilule a de quoi toi j'aime bien lui en
plus j'avais aussi j'adore taille est
super enfin vignolles ils vous attendent
le tout c'est pas du tout ça je vous
dire ce que c'est c'est quand tu te lave
les mains
mais qu'il est lourd c'est du gel
hydroalcoolique j'en suis sûre d'avoir
lancé un débat important alors fouillé
dans la journée avait fourché sur un mot
vous avez corps chiens n'ont pas de
panique dites vous qu'il y aura toujours
pire que vous dans la vie c'est l'heure
de nick sa grammaire c'est pas donc pour
l'instant je vais analyser jouer
observer et à diesse kg poids pas
comment il peut hésiter entre mais les
mois enfin je suis en train de cracher
du sud chomel mes mails doit découvre
moi cette écoute parce que les on dit tu
peux pas juger l'oreille droite ce qu'on
a vécu tous pouvaient passer je connais
pas mal quand je vois la caisse que je
me trouve moches mais qu'est-ce que je
ressemble à marie charlotte empoigné
français il galère mais du coup est ce
que en anglais c'est mieux s'il y avait
un truc en particulier i want the thing
une tactique les mois
un petit truc sans la police exactement
les émissions de police ça cartonne 90
minutes enquête enquêtes prioritaires au
coeur de l'enquète mais luigi ce serait
fou situe beaucoup nous faire un spécial
police
et ben oui c'est parti on commence par
l'histoire d'un mec qui était bien
décidé à appeler la gendarmerie le sens
bien c'est la gendarmerie pour ouvrir
celle à jean maury monsieur oui c'est
moi c'est l'agent abbas et moi les
schmidt
nous sortons s'il vous plaît pour la
retrouver le gars le plus content au
monde de se faire arrêter
il va falloir vous l'écrivez une amende
de 90 euros venez avec moi
[Musique]
villeneuve loubet promis on ne boit
jamais d'alcool gendarmes de villeneuve
loubet aussi est interdit de boire de
l'alcool sur maintenant patrick au
courant pour signer un pv il faut au
moins un bac + 5
on signe désormais son pv de façon
électronique
non il ya un client ou signer le bouton
non non le résultat n'est pas
convaincant gagne tout à fait mais ça
c'est génial et enfin sarah se tape
tellement la honte qu'elles risquent pas
de ressortir de chèques tout de suite
sarah n'a aucun papier sur elle mais son
nom est inscrit sur une boîte de
médicaments
c'est quoi ça et c'est suffisant pour
nous hisser cox très bien
c'est une pommade anti-euro it merci au
revoir il est en partie par partie
exactement sans un peu de la télé tout
le monde connait tik tok
ah oui ça j'avais moi j'aimerais bien
qu'à l'apport des petites vidéos courtes
marrante c'est tout de suite le top tic
toc
et justement isabelle morini bosc a
intégré le casting du dernier jurassic
park et les images ont fuité sur tic toc
[Musique]
vous hésitez encore le sport ou
reprendre du dessert on a trouvé la
solution et après son régime bazin m'a
castaldi a repris un peu de poids et
c'est pas sa voisine qui dira le
contraire elle a bercé mon luigi
[Applaudissements]